this nice comfortable chair here yes yes
and this is kind of i don't really know
what to make of this
what do you actually do what do you mean
i think that's a very nice chair i was
in my apartment for like four years oh
how kind of you to bring it this it's
just a little i'm not quite sure i kind
of want to face you but then i'm here
i'm not sure what to do it's your choice
as an actor you make a choice and you
stick with it and look what my chair
does i need some direction but you go up
and down
goes down
i can't do that this actually i i hit
this lever once accidentally during an
interview and it fell and i didn't know
it and then i was just like this the
rest of the time
well that's good this desk is it looks
much much smaller than i thought it
stayed small everything so what if i was
just this whole hey joaquin what's up
really
yeah
it's like the dwarf on golf video so how
are you doing really good you uh you um
you seem thrilled to be here which is
cool uh
i know you don't love these fantastic
yeah no um
i'm curious about something we're gonna
talk about buffalo soldiers in just a
second but you just finished shooting
for like six months on a movie that's
about firefighters where you had to
pretty much train to be a real
firefighter yeah which for a lot of
people like you know a lot of kids
growing up that would be like a cool fun
thing to do i used to love fire houses
when i was a kid i used to thought like
it'd be cool to go down the fire pole
did you do that
well i majored in cowardice at cal state
so really i wasn't really built for that
kind of thing right i meant to sit in a
rocking chair and like smoke a pipe and
that kind of thing right right so i i go
down there and yeah it was the first
thing to do going to get a fire fight
you got to you know slide down the pole
and i got up there and i looked down and
i was like i can't do that you're crazy
because it's i'm certain that you land
and your feet just go up into your torso
and then
then you walk around like in a cartoon
i'm not kidding it's very scary you look
down it's very scary so
um it's just so humiliating i knew this
was going to happen to me i i they had
to uh they got a ladder and they put it
next to the pole and i went up like
three rungs and like slid down i was
i'm very proud of myself and then they
gave you a cookie you know yeah it was
amazing yeah then i went up five rungs
i finally made it to the top and that
was really amazing i felt triumphant now
you actually had what what what was
you you actually got into a situation
where you were mistaken for a real
fireman and you had to try and come to
the rescue is that true
yeah well not the rescue but
i'd gone down to the firehouse and the
guys had gone on a run i missed them i
was with one of the kids in the movie
about sargetti and these uh undercover
cops came up and they said they needed
help with the forceful entry and they
didn't recognize you guys no we're in
our blues and you know we're at the
firehouse and and so i said yeah sure
thing you know and i'm going what the
hell are we going to do so i run i grab
this huge battering ram it takes like
six people to do it and the cop looks at
it and he's like you're not gonna need
that man you probably just take a
haligan which is a tool that they use
like a large crowbar right so we went
down there and we go to the door and
they point out the door and
we have no idea what to do we don't know
how to open this did you have this tool
cool we were holding it we looked good
yeah we just didn't know
that's all that's nine tenths of it
isn't it for the movie but here we are
in real life we gotta open this door
right so we so we worked at this thing
and honestly it was like 15 minutes and
and the cops were just they were out now
laughing at us like there was there's
nothing more you could do so i mean i
tried everything and i did the kind of
shoulder thing and i literally bounced
off the door and went down the stairs
because i've always thought that i see
it in the movies but when you really
every time i've run up against the door
and put my shoulder to it nothing
happened you tried that as well i've
tried it together i'm always trying to
break into women's rooms
move on it's your story now
i know it started getting dark and i was
uncomfortable and this should be fun
it's gonna be a fun show exactly i tried
i tried to get the band playing a good
music up front and they played the march
of the elephants
i liked that that was very quick how you
did the marching elephants thing i like
that oh good thank you i'm always trying
i'm always killing time out here i wanna
let's talk about in buffalo soldiers you
shot this uh buffalo soldiers in germany
and one thing i got to go to germany
once for like a day on business and i
really always wanted to go on the
autobahn did you get to drive on the
autobahn
conan that is just so funny that you
asked me that
i you know are you ready do you have an
autobahn story you read my money do you
have an autobahn storyboard oh this is
[Applause]
crazy don't know how you do it that is
weird it's almost as if someone called
you yesterday and you talked it's like i
had a free interview oh wow
i don't know how you do it you know what
you're addicted you're gifted it's a
gift
you don't question it don't question it
it's beautiful use it take advantage
come to my mind and i ask
so the autobahn
well
no it's not now it's like totally
anticlimactic i can't tell the story i
mean this whole bit was much funnier
what a great way to get out of telling a
story no you're a very crafty guy a
little bit the story well i was just
always excited about the audubon because
there's no rules i just thought it
speed line was fantastic
there's no speed limit and um and then i
i did it and i was driving on it and it
was the most terrifying experience i've
ever had in my life i thought like this
should be illegal but that's what i was
thinking
and i guess it is here yeah they're
there to go with it but it's like it's
it's so strange because you have to be
like a hawkeye you have to see your exit
a mile in advance or else you're going
so fast they kind of look up you're like
is that okay and then
and it's gone right right and that's it
and so i kind of just i kind of gave up
on the whole exit thing at some point
and we basically
we just kept driving because your brakes
don't like after 300 miles an hour the
brakes aren't gonna really do anything
right i mean you're going not speed they
kind of just go like you know mate
you're on your own
i have english freaks you're the british
they're brilliant you mean german breaks
no you're whatnot stop now
but i i don't know i think that the uh i
think the exits just kind of launch you
in a spaceship sure yeah i i don't think
it actually goes down it's kind of i
don't even want now i don't want to go
and try it it sounds too frightening to
me i like 55. i'm not trying to go just
nice and easy leisurely you take in the
sights a little bit put on cruise
control yeah it's terrifying yeah
so i favor this area now and i liked it
when you were looking at me
all right look out of them
oh okay i'm gonna favor this
whoa what's this mean what's the big red
thing it's like hey let's shoot that
that's the red rap that i get hey look
at this angle right here does this look
like a cool album cover joaquin and i
made an album
look hot do your hard lifts do the hard
lift
what's that do a hard look dude okay
wait just turn away from me for a second
close your eyes now when i call your
name just give me your hardest look yes
sir okay conan
nice
nice
yes you did just say that yeah i can't
say that
come on we can do anything we want we
rule the night nice
nice you know we have to show this clip
from buffalo soldiers we have a clip
here from buffalo soldiers which said
that i didn't have to leave it you don't
have to yeah i get the word he doesn't
want to set it up so i'll set up the
clip here's what we uh i was in buffalo
soldiers and uh
i'll be you
and i play this scheming soldier i'm
always scheming kind of like a bilco
character and ed harris is my uh
commanding officer he doesn't know what
i'm up to here's a clip of me trying to
scam him
what is this what are we here i do some
requisition sir
1 000 gallons
of mop and glow my god do we really need
that much well cleanliness is next to
godliness
how do you do manfront how are you doing
just fine doing just fine so we do some
business today sure thing guys
i think you'll be pleased
and look at the sparkle that's real
cleaning power it's a good chai so yeah
see we'll try something
u.s army's finest 500 gallons ready to
go
you're a bad man buffalo soldiers opens
tomorrow in select cities right
expanding further in the uh in the weeks
ahead yeah you know what yes do they
have to beep out the scheisse yeah no
it's german for the bad word is that are
they cool with that german for what
we'll be right
that's all right no take care of no
we'll take care of the whole thing and
you're going to make it i have so much
power over late night television that i
can yeah america will accept it tonight
because i say so you know what it was
very cool having you here thank you that
was great joaquin phoenix scott thompson
coming up we'll take a break